ve hadi dedi
[Müzik]
herkes birbirini sever
fazla
[Müzik]
bu
ve
[Müzik]
gönderiyor ama temelde
D
Ancak
[Müzik]
bu sivilce görünümleri
Tanrı
hatta bazen
[Müzik]
benim adım
ve
doğrusu
buldum
One Love
Hadi gidelim
[Müzik]
şaraba
birçok
Bazı
o bizdik
[Müzik]
Evet
Suçlu
Bilmiyorum
15 7
daha fazlası
İsa
on bir
onların hareketleri
[Müzik]
ama hiçbir şey
Y
kolay
gerçekten
birçok
Y
yıllar
[Müzik]
kendisi
adlandırıldı
bu telefonla
Tanrı
daha çok yerim
aynısı
bir hortum
hadi arena kullanıcıları
çözücüler ile
ve diğerleri
[Müzik]
Tanrı
son
Y
Evet
johansson
Ey
veya
buda düğmesi ve ne kadar iyi
[Müzik]
dır-dir
bugün rüzgar
xl
bilmek
işlev
[Müzik]
veya
burada
ya da değil
[Müzik]
dans
bazı disney yollarında
[Müzik]
kuyu
Ne
sadece sosyal olarak değil
[Müzik]
Y
bu böyle
D
Hayır
yada daha fazla
bu normal
Y
aklın
ilk deprem son durumu
para
[Müzik]
Görüşürüz
inek öğrenci
bir tek
Evet
biz
Hadi gidelim
olabilir
aynı ile gidiyoruz
Evet
telefonda ve eğer bayrak taşıyorsa
Merhaba
omuzlarım
bir şey
[Müzik]
ve ben
Hayır
s
Evet
farzedelim
bölgede
baba
[Alkış]